Since its inception in 2010, The Walking Dead has
earned its place as a long-running TV classic.
Despite its overwhelming popularity, though,
it's by no means immune to criticism.
We're here to show you some unpopular opinions
about The Walking Dead that raise good points.
We're definitely not the first to notice that The
Walking Dead plays like an inverted Star Trek.
According to the imagination of Gene Roddenberry,
post-current civilization humanity cooperates,
prospers, and revels in scientific
advancement and exploration. Meanwhile,
people in The Walking Dead universe form tribes
and go to war against each other, instead of
pooling their resources and working together
against an obvious and omnipresent common threat.
While Star Trek is optimistic, The
Walking Dead goes a step beyond pessimism
into full-blown nihilism. For whoever's
left of the gang, their victories don't
really matter because they live in a world
that's already been conquered by walkers.
They just survive terrible things in
order to survive more terrible things.
Therefore, if the series ends with anything
other than all the characters becoming dinner,
it will have betrayed its central themes
of futility and doom. Considering the fact
that the writers have sometimes significantly
deviated from the graphic novels' trajectory,
there's no way of knowing if this inevitable
conclusion will come to pass on-screen.
At one point in 2006's Clerks II, the
character of Randal Graves goes on a
little diatribe to explain his contempt for
the Lord of the Rings trilogy. As he puts it:
"All it was was a bunch of people walking."
Well, if you replace "walking" with
"killing zombies" in Randal's rant,
it's not an inaccurate
description of The Walking Dead.
We're definitely not saying the show has ever
gotten boring. In order to get truly boring,
it would have to reduce its seasonal body
count to a degree that would make it a
different show entirely. But it goes without
saying that things have gotten repetitive.
Rick and the crew struggle against the elements
until they find the Greene family farm. After
walkers overrun the farm, the heroes set out
on their own once again. Then they come to the
prison, and they live there until walkers take
over that one, too. Same deal in Alexandria. In
other words, The Walking Dead has a formula,
and it sticks to that formula pretty closely.
If a corporation makes a successful
thing — it could be a TV show, film,
book, what have you — then its next step will be
to recreate whatever that thing happened to be,
in hopes of similar monetary rewards. In a
vacuum, that's not a bad impulse. It's why
film genres exist in the first place. But
we've hit a point where big companies fear
taking risks on just about anything
they don't think is a sure-fire hit.
For proof, look no further than
the world of The Walking Dead.
After all, Fear the Walking Dead,
The Walking Dead: World Beyond,
and any other Dead-adjacent television projects in
development exist at the expense of an unknowable
number of other shows that weren't greenlit
because they lacked a built-in audience.
Perhaps we shouldn't judge AMC too harshly for its
decision-making process because that's also why we
got Better Call Saul. But it is worth asking —
at what point do we no longer require expansions
on a story that gets accused of redundancy and
spinning its wheels as often as The Walking Dead?
Are The Walking Dead fans
all jerks? Of course not!
But there's a significant minority
among the fandom that's pretty toxic.
For proof, look no further than Josh McDermitt's
social media experience. The actor has received
death threats because some fans dislike the
character he plays — the cowardly Eugene.
Of course, if McDermitt responded in kind to each
and every crazed fan who threatened his life over
the actions of an imaginary person he plays on
television, then McDermitt would look insane,
and that would interfere with his
ability to gain further employment
as a Hollywood actor. His only other option was to
quit social media, and we can't say we blame him.
McDermitt's far from the only cast
member to deal with online strife. Sadly,
fans body-shamed Alanna Masterson, prompting both
the actress and costar Steven Ogg to strike back,
encouraging trolls to, quote, "go f---ing
do something productive with your life."
When Michonne Hawthorne first appears at the
end of season two, we see her leading around
two walkers on leashes. Later, we find out that
these are the reanimated corpses of her boyfriend
and her boyfriend's pal. Evidently, she mutilated
their bodies due to some justified resentment
connected to the death of her son. But in the
process, Michonne discovered that walkers become
docile and harmless once their mouths and arms are
removed. Even better, she learned that surrounding
herself with armless, mouthless walkers rendered
her invisible to actively hostile zombies.
So, why isn't every living person dragging a
pair of neutered walkers with them at all times?
If there's an effective method
of walker deterrent available,
why is Michonne the only person
who ever uses it? Furthermore,
why does she only use it when it's supposed
to symbolize her paranoia and isolation?
This is a list of opinions, of course.
It could very well be that people don't
want to stand next to mutilated walkers
24/7 because that would be a completely
disgusting way to live. But once
you got used to it, in our opinion,
being constantly safe from walkers is worth
being constantly grossed out by walkers.
Let's talk about October of 2016. Fans
had waited all summer to find out whose
skull Negan would shatter at the onset of the
seventh season. The season premiere started,
and we all held on to our butts, anticipating a
payoff that would validate all our theories and
arguments over who had the best guess.
After a handful of eternal minutes,
we watched both Abraham and Glenn face
immensely unpleasant blunt-force deaths.
And it was gory. Disturbingly so. And
there's something strange about the
fact that the show made us wait so long,
made us debate and wonder and speculate,
only to treat us to a truly brutal
beatdown that left us all feeling queasy.
Granted, nobody on The Walking Dead is ever
safe. That looming uncertainty is written into
the genre's DNA. But in the lead-up to season
seven, the uncertainty gave way to a kind of
sadism that one might use to promote a snuff
film, and that raises uncomfortable questions.
"You are not safe."
Why were we so excited to watch someone die? Is
there something wrong with us? Do we need help?
And did the show step over the
line with those brutal killings?
So, if you tell us Rick Grimes seems
like a nice guy, you'll get no argument.
The protagonist played by Andrew Lincoln
sticks by his friends and family,
and always tries to do the honorable thing.
But, perhaps by design, he's not what
we'd call a fascinating individual.
In fact, as a sheriff's deputy with
a wife and child in suburban Georgia,
he was living a pretty typical life before the
world ended. Circumstances in subsequent years
inspired considerable intensity from Grimes,
but there's not a ton else that makes him feel
intrinsically unique. He didn't rise out of
an abusive relationship like Carol. He's not
the most charismatic person in the room at
all times, a la Daryl. He isn't an awesome
swordsman like Michonne. He doesn't even have
a memorable gimmick like Jesus or Ezekiel.
In some respects, he's similar to John
Connor in the Terminator franchise.
The other characters look to Rick Grimes as
a leader, and they clearly draw a tremendous
amount of inspiration from his words and deeds.
But nobody ever gets all that specific about what,
precisely, makes this guy so special.
Ultimately, this places Rick Grimes in
the same category as Buffy Summers and Jerry
Seinfeld — thoroughly effective main characters
who are nevertheless bland as dishwater
when compared to all of their friends.
The series premiered in 2010, about a year
before the emergence of its contemporaries,
Game of Thrones and Once Upon a Time. These
ensemble dramas all felt designed to fill the
void left by Lost -- which infamously
dangled solutions to the Island's many
mysteries inches in front of its audience's
proverbial face throughout six seasons.
Likewise, The Walking Dead gang's journey in
season one to the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention led us to assume the origin of
the infection might be explained at some point.
Since then, many seasons have aired. And
in all that time, characters have rarely
expressed interest in any big picture beyond
immediate necessity, and it seems unlikely that
anybody still tuning in expects to find
out what started the zombie apocalypse.
One could argue that attaching a clear-cut
cause for the end of civilization undercuts
the themes of random suffering and mayhem
that permeate throughout the rest of the show.
So if the series never explains where the walker
infection came from, it won't be a worse show for
allowing its big mystery to go unsolved. In fact,
it's probably safer to leave that particular rock
unturned, rather than offering up a disappointing
explanation that wasn't even needed to begin with.
As we learned in September of 2020, season eleven
of The Walking Dead will be its last. Regardless
of how the spinoffs have turned out or will turn
out, AMC made a good decision here. In fact,
if they made a mistake at all, it was not lopping
off the show's aging head a few years earlier.
In fact, why would AMC ever continue a
beloved sci-fi/horror series well after
its quality and fan interest started to decline?
Did AMC executives not learn the
tragic lesson of The X-Files?
When it started in 1993, The X-Files
became a surprise pop cultural phenomenon,
much like The Walking Dead would years later.
Also like The Walking Dead, The X-Files probably
should've tied off all its loose story threads
and called it a day sometime around season 5 or 6.
Instead, the network dragged it out
for nine seasons and two movies,
plus a revival years later. Seasons ten and
eleven aren't complete and total garbage,
but their worst entries — particularly the
cringe-inducing "My Struggle IV " — are
bafflingly terrible to a degree that
damages the legacy of the entire series.
In its defense, The Walking Dead has
never produced an episode as abysmal
as "My Struggle IV." But the show won't have
officially dodged that bullet until it ends.
Calling it quits at season eleven was
a good — albeit belated — decision.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.